[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
لمخرج وكاتب ممثل في مسرح
مصر الحقيقي
[موسيقى]
فيجن بيسمع بشكل مستمر صوت الراجل الطائر
بردمان جوه دماغه بينتقد كل تصرفاته
وبيسخر من مسرحياته خلال الفيلم هتشوف
ريجن وهو معتقد انه عنده قوه خارقه بيطير
وبيحرك الحاجات بعقله وهتشوف تاثير
اعتقاده ده عليه بعد ما رجعن بيفضل في
حياته المهنيه بيقرر يبدا بكتابه واخراج
واداء دور البطوله في مسرحي المسرحيه
ماخوذه من رواه قصيره للكاتب ريموند
بعنوان عن ما نتحدث حين نتحدث عن الحب
وعلى الرغم من محاولات رجال الواضحه جدا
بس صوت الرجل الطائر مان كل شويه بيظهر له
ويقول له يبعد عن المسرحيه وان مكانه مش
هنا مكانه في السينما بين النجوم
الحقيقيين
اللي بيساعد رجل يستمر رغم كل المشاعر
الصعبه اللي بيمر بها هو صديق قوه جيك جيك
افضل صديق لرجن وكمان المحامي بتاعه
وشريكه في انتاج المسرحيه جيك بيبقى مع
رجل من اول لحظه بيحاول يهديه في الهوات
الصعبه ويبعد عنه الصحفيين اللي بيتطفلوا
عليه في اوقات ثانيه هتشوف بين الرجل
بيقرر انه مش هيكمل المسرحيه وكل مره
بيقول على نفسه ان مش قادر بس جيك بيكون
موجود علشان يشجعه ويخليك كمان مش هيك بس
كان موجود صديقته واللي شركته بطوله
المسرحيه وانضم لها في البطوله كمان بعدها
احكي لك عن علاقتهم ببعض كمان شويه خلينا
شركه الصعوبات اللي هيواجهها ريجن من
بدايه الشغل على المسرحيه خلال البروفات
هيكون في بطوله المسرحيه رالف واللي هيكون
تمثيله سيء جدا بالنسبه
لهم في التمارين هيقع على دماغ رولس مصباح
يتسبب في عدم مشاركته مسرحيه وقتها هتشوف
ريجن وهو معتقد ان هو السبب وانه وقع
المصباح فوق دماغه ايه كان بيرفض بشده
دخول اي بطل مبتدئ وبيصر على وجود ممثل
محترف وده هيعصب جيد جدا لكذا سبب منهم ان
ما فيش وقت وكمان ان فلوسهم بتخلص لحد ما
نزل هتقول لهم ان صديقها مايك متاح مايك
ممثل لامع وموهوب هيسح الريجا من اول اداء
ليه وهيصره على وجوده على الرغم ان جيك
بيرفض بسبب الرقم اللي كان طلبه لكن من
كثر هاوس وبنجاح المسرحيه بيروح يرهن بيته
علشان يعرف يحاسب مايك على اداء الدور
وبالرغم من كل ده في اول ظهور تجريبي
المايك هيتعصب جدا ويبوظ المسرحيه قدام
الجمهور بسبب انه كان بيشرب خمره حقيقيه
لانه
خلاص بقوا مفلسين وبعدها بهدل ايجن لكن
العداوه بينهم هتزيد لما مايك يظهر في
مقابله مع نيويورك تايمز وياخذ كل الاضواء
وكمان يتكلم عن ريجنن بشكل غير لائق وقتها
هيتطور ويوصل الصراع لحد الضرب فظل كل
الظروف دي بيروح ريجن و مايكل يشربه
بيشوفوا الكافيه الناقده تيكن اللي هتكتب
على المسرحياتهم ولما بيتكلم معها مايك
بتقول له انا هادمر المسرحيه دي وده بسبب
اعتقادها ان رجل مش ممثل اصلا وان هو بس
مجرد شخص مشهور بسبب شخصيه ظهرت ونجحت في
وقت من الاوقات ريجن بيكون بيمر بكذا صراع
صراع ما بينه وما بين نفسه بينه وما بين
مايك بينه وما بين باقي الفريق انه بيحاول
يضبط كل حاجه بينه بامراته والاهم بينه
وبين بنته سام سام بتساعد رجل المسرحيه
لكنها كمان بتتعافى صراع رجل مع انسان
مختلفه
اللي بيخاف جدا على بنته وبيصور تماما لما
بيعرف ان هي رجعت للشرب تاني ولما
بيتصادموا وسامه بتقول له انه نكره وما
حدش اساسا مهتم بمسرحيه ساذجه زي دي لكن
بيتاثر جدا وبيشوف نفسه اب فاشل وغير
مسؤول هما جواه عارف ان الاسباب اللي خلت
سام توصل للادمان وهيعترف بتقصيره ناحيتها
ولزوجته في نهايه الفيلم هيسوق الوضع لما
رجع يشوف مايك وسام سوا في الكواليس هيطلع
علشان يشرب سيجاره بره المسرح فالباب
بيتقفل على هدومه وهو ما بيعرفش يفتحوه
وبيطر الخلع الروب ويمشي في الشوارع
تقريبا شبه عاري وهنا بتكون لمعه جديده
للرجال اللي انا هنشوف كل الناس عارفينه
كلهم بيحاولوا يتصوروا معه وبيسالوه مش
هترجع ثاني في جزء من الراجل الطائر
الثاني
وخلال ساعات قليله جدا هيكون تريند وكل
الناس وكل القنوات
وبيكمل المشهد ولا كاني في اي حاجه غريبه
وهيكون مبدل المسدس المزيف بمسدس حقيقي
فلما يطلع على المسرح ويؤدي المشهد الاخير
قدام الجماهير بالمسدس بيضرب نفسه بالنار
بتسود بعدها حاله انبهار وتسقيف من الكل
واعتقدهم منه ان هو ده التمثيل المصاحبه
بتنجح جدا والنقاض بتكتب مقال مميز عنها
وبينزل في الصفحه الاولى ريجن هيعيش دائما
مناخير صناعيه وهيقرر يبطل يسمع لصوت
الفيرنا مان تمام بس ايه اللي هيحصل في
المشهد النهائي وهل كل ده حصل على المسرح
ده اللي هاسيبك تعرفه لما تشوف الفيلم
وتكتشف تفاصيل مميزه هتفرق معك فيلم
كوميدي سنه 2014
كريسبورج وايمي براين الفيلم لما نزل تلقى
اشادات كبيره جدا من النقاد لدرجه ان تم
اعتباره احد افضل افلام 2014 من منظمات
زيه معهد الفيلم الامريكي والمجلس الوطني
المرجعه هترشح الفيلم لسبع جوائز جولدن
جلوب في حفله ثاني و70 من ضمنها افضل فيلم
وافضل سيناريو وافضل مخرج وفاز بافضل
سيناريو الممثل كي 10 فاز بجائزه افضل
ممثل عن دوره في تقديم شخصيه ريجن ونورتن
واما اترشحوا لافضل الممثل مساعد وافضل
ممثله مساعده على التوالي وفي حفله توزيع
جوائز الاوسكار السابع والثمانين فاز
الفيلم بجائزه افضل فيلم وافضل مخرج لجونز
وكمان افضل سيناريو اصلي وافضل تصوير
سينمائي من اصل 9 اشهر
بكل تفاصيله شوف الفيلم دلوقتي واستنان
الحلقه اللي جايه من فيلم جديد كاست مهاره
الافلام المقدم من العربيه
[موسيقى]